hello uh my name is rayal offic i'm a
principal researcher
in microsoft research lab in redmond
my main interests are virtual reality
augmented reality and haptics and today
i will talk about
using uh virtual reality and augmented
reality
as a place to do work
when you're on the go and
let's go so the concept of the office
as we know it is changing more people
are working from
home and locations farm from the
physical office
or while on the move
this progress have accelerated with the
covet 19 pandemic and their resulting
lockdowns it
introduced many positive effects such as
unable to work at flexible hours
and reduce commute time enable
people that are far from the office
location
to work and being more accessible
for uh people with physical limitations
however it also has
limitations people have to work in
less than optimal workspace
they have limited display for example a
laptop screen
when you work on a train or in a
makeshift
office rather than an arrangement of
multiple
video screen that you might have or at
work
it has less than optimal lighting
there's a
problem of privacy and prying eyes all
around you
um disturbances
and in the later years you see
people working on a plurality of devices
from
laptop to tablet to phone
and how we can leverage all of them for
uh
one workspace
now if we look on virtual reality its
technology has progressed by leap and
bounds
uh we can now buy uh
cheaper headsets that are aimed at
consumer market they're lighter
their resolution is gradually growing we
can already buy
headsets with resolution of about 2000
by 2000 pixels which
uh getting to uh the good
monitors that people use for work and
they have
inside out tracking of the head
using cameras that are mounting on the
uh headsets and those allow us to work
everywhere
not just in rooms that were prepared for
uh
tracking they allow us to track the
hands
as they move around controllers and
they also allow to pass the video from
outside
inside the display without the need to
uh took off
take off the headsets
and much of the hype around vr
i've been focused on immersive
applications such as gaming and
entertainment
and in this webinar i'm trying to focus
on the use of those vr headset for
productivity and how to overcome
problems that
i mentioned we suggest a
novel immersive workspace that will be
on one hand use large
display page which is organized in a
familiar manner
oh that looks like my office it will
have an optical lighting it will
[Music]
protect whatever we work on from prying
eyes
and will reduce uh
destruction in a selective manner some
people that are approaches we want to uh
get to know about that their approach
however we are doing something which is
different than
most vr applications and we limit the
user input space
to a very small space and there's a
reason for that
if we look at applications that exist
right now to let people move around the
space
reach with their hand to virtual objects
which is very engaging but
when you are in a limited space that
might be a problem also when you do
large gestures such as reaching
out and using hands in the air this
requires a lot of
effort and it's hard to do such a work
for a long time after
most vr applications after 15
30 minutes we are already quite
exhausted
so by using uh small motions
that are mostly uh supported by our
devices
by desk we enable to
uh let the user work for longer hours
and use their uh gestures and muscle
memory even
when the environment changes but we want
them to be able to control
a large display space around them
so let's look at different tasks that we
need to do for the information worker
let's start with
a very basic one typing how do we type
in virtual reality um usually
as applications looks at people that are
standing moving
they tend to use large keyboards that
you
point on them with controllers or with
hands but
you use large displacement of the hands
to minimize typing mistakes
well this is good for a moving user it
mostly aim at
uh sporadic short input sequences
rather than full editing of a document
we need to change our thinking of a
design from
uh large energetic
motions to uh
sitting with a good posture
and ergonomics where our
gestures and hand and hands are
supported
and which allows us to do
a very delicate selections and for a
long period
so if we think about sitting people
and entering text by far the most common
way to enter text is using a qwerty
keyboard which heaven although they're
not necessarily the best
or uh haven't changed in the last
century and a half
mostly due to the familiarity of people
with them
and we want to leverage on that
familiarity
and the haptic feedback that we do get
from a physical keyboard
and continue enjoy that also in virtual
reality however
in virtuality we put a head mounted
display on our head and as such we block
the view
of the hands and the keyboards from the
user
so some users know touch typing well
and they can continue typing just by
looking at the documents but
we want everybody to be able to use
the keyboard one option is to allow
visibility of the keyboard and the hand
by cutting the part of the display
some of the display will be the document
and some
we can look down glance and see our
hands
while reducing the immersivity of the
experience it's also
uh doesn't let us
do different effects that we will talk
about later
when we are working in a virtual world
so
uh but this is a legitimate uh way to go
uh just as well as using the cameras on
the headset to stream
video of our hands and keyboard in real
time
to the user
and finally we can use those cameras and
computer vision to
track their hands track the keyboard
track the
devices and display them as virtual
object in the
virtual space already
existing devices such from
hololens to oculus quest to
htc vive pro enables uh such
tracking in real time and we can also
use for our benefit effect that the
keyboard
has a fixed view or we can use the
display
of the devices which we don't see
because of the head mounted display
to show different information that can
help the tracking
so um in this case we need to
display uh the keyboards display the
hand display the working environment
in virtual reality is
what will be the best we just uh talked
about different ways of doing so
and usually the way that we could
um
[Music]
check that is via studies
so let's start about how what will be
the best way to
represent our hands when we typing
we mentioned four options one was
don't show the hands at all maybe just
as a
touch type is to show which keys are
being pressed
and the update of the document we can
just as well show a real-time video
of the hands we can model the hands as
fully fleshed 3d models that type on a
virtual keyboard
or maybe something totally different for
example
show the tips of the fingertips as if
our hands are transparent and we can see
the
uh keyboard through them what would
people will prefer so when you give
participants a chance to
type text in those modes we can see
several things one
is that the speed of typing almost never
change
regardless of the mode but the quality
of typing the number
of errors that people do do change
and while we expected video to be a very
good
representation as close as possible to
uh
real life it's uh surprising to see that
just rendering the fingertips is almost
as good
another surprise is that when you give a
full model
of the hands we found out the number of
errors increases almost the same
as not showing the hand at all what's
happening there
it might be due to uh small
differences in the tracking and the
uncanny effect which
people look at the hand and say that's
not
my hand it's artificial hand and
although
they do type it has some
lowering of quality
when asked people what do they like they
mostly like the video because the
closest to uh uh
real life but again surprising enough
the
uh the fingertips
are not far behind
what about the position of where our
hands and keyboards
when we look at people typing in vr uh
we see
that they have less than perfect pose
when they tap
and there's a reason for that when you
look through
head mounted display you notice that
displays have a limited vertical
field of view which many times
you cannot see both the hand and the
keyboard which are
on the table and the document you added
which
many times is in front of you to make
things worse
we actually if we look at the lenses
that uh those uh head mounted display
use
they're not perfect either and they're
uh are non-uniform they're much worse
next to the edges of the display which
lowers the practical
field of view in which you can read text
even further so wouldn't it be
nice if we could take uh the
hands and keyboards which may be
rendered as a virtual
object and just move them close to
where the uh uh the document is being
typed and away
from where their physical hands are
would that
disturb the users so
that's exactly what we did we uh move
the keyboard and the hand and retarget
them to be
close to uh the user's
view direction and as you can see the
pose
is immediately become
better what about typing
so when we look at that surprisingly
enough
if we look at physical keyboards the
yellow ones
on the top uh there is a basically
same uh performance
whether the keyboards are where they're
physically are
or if we show them floating in the air
where the user is looking at regarding
touch keyboard there is
some uh there is some reduction
in performance and that's probably to
the fact
that we need to disconnect our fingers
from the glass
and then reconnect and then that
movement in the air
is more susceptible to a change of
orientation
as big as three degrees as we used in
this experiment however
regardless of what the keyboard is there
is
a great improvement in head pitch which
is mostly
looking forward and not down as it used
to be
before what about the keyboard itself we
talked about how we
may render the hands differently but we
can also change how the keyboard looks
like and you can see that in real life
in
specialized keyboards such as gamer
keyboards keyboards that has
shortcuts on them such in control rooms
here we have a virtual keyboard display
we can actually change it
every minute according to the need
so when we come to uh look at
possibility of changing keyboard we can
uh distinguish of two axis two
axes of design one the first one
is how we interpret the use of uh
a click on a keyboard the first uh
option is what we familiar with in real
world when we
click on a button in the keyboard it's
regarded as
one press of one key but
since you might not see the keyboard as
it is
we can actually have different type of
inputs
for example we could have a
multiple group of keys just behave as if
it's one big
key and no matter where we press in it
what the system will
get is that key input
and we can go with that even further
let's assume the whole keyboard is one
key what's the
information that we get there we assume
the keyboard is
if it's a touch screen or
it has an x and y axises and we
what we care about is where the user
is actually putting its finger and
in fact we could even have a higher
resolution
than the keys if we look at
multiple key presses and see that
the user actually press in between
keys so that's
input let's talk about the display or
the output
the most common way
is the graphics that each key has on it
we can change that
according to applications for example
you can think of applications such as
lowercase
uppercase different languages and
different languages not just per key
for example here when we type in german
every
character might have other ways
of writing it with additional marks
so by as you type you actually
show the different variation of each
character
so you could uh that
have another click to change that uh
view now usually this is not very
uh efficient because the user has to
break out from the document and look
down on the keyboard but again in our
case we can bring the keyboard
just where next the user is typing and
show the options with the
finger and that which makes it more
efficient
um we can use application shortcuts
jumping i'll tab to different
applications
tabs on in
on the browser and ways that are
changing according to the current
arrangement
uh that we have on the screen
we don't have to remember them in our uh
head also we can use that to
enable better privacy for example i'm
say working on a plane and i want to
type in passwords
i don't want to reveal that for people
around me
and we could use change the mapping
between the keys and or semantics
and there's a range of options here that
has a trade-off between more shuffle and
security
to uh easier or faster
typing according to the need
but we can change more than just the
graphics on each key we can
start changing the keys themselves
because the user does not see the
keyboard so
we can have bigger keys if we want for a
stronger semantic action for example
one space movement
two entries movement or jump to the end
of the line
could have different size of keys
and this could change according to
our needs for example here we have a
window manager where we press alt tab
and we see what
applications are there and then we can
immediately jump to an application by
pressing the button now the less number
of locations we can have bigger
buttons so it will be less effort to
select them we can also change the size
of the application according to the view
direction
of the user which we get from the head
mount and display so that applications
which are
probably the user looks at will appear
bigger and easier to select
we can use that to browse
different medias and again
here we show here use the resolution of
the keyboard for a
selection and obviously you can have
multiple uh
keyboard layouts and page between them
and maybe the most interesting is
how can we break the mold of the
keyboard and and use it in a totally
different way for example
uh maybe ignore the rest of the keyboard
and just look at the functionality that
we need
and uh to uh demonstrate
that uh you can see for example here
access
to a timeline of a video by using the
raw the upper row of digits
now although it looks like there's 10
selections there
within position of the video you can
actually
press in between keys and have
more selectivity over there now
you only need that line what if we'll
only show the line to the user not the
full keyboard
it does help people to use to focus on
that task but on the other hand can
generate
accidents because you might hit parts of
the keyboard that you're not aware of
so uh representation such as the top
left where you are focusing on the keys
but also aware that there is a mass
around it that you should aware not to
hit
might be better for such uses
so we can take those two accesses and
generate a design space where different
application
might be use different inputs uh
and different outputs for example the
one on the top right
is our implementation of
a whack-a-mole game where the whole
keyboard
is just one key and it sends where
the hand or the hammer touches it
what about the screen when we work on a
tablet
we use a 2d screen which is our entire
display space
our entire input space maybe i'm again
sitting on
an airplane and put my tablet on the
tray and work
and on one hand it's great my hand is
supported by the tablet
i'm not getting tired but it has very
limited
uh input space and display
so we can use the fact that we have
wearing a head mounted display to enrich
on this environment for start
we can look at the space above the
tablet although the hand
is lying on the glass it could still
tilt the stylus up
and reach higher points in that space
which for example we can use to generate
different layers of different semantics
at different heights and of course
we can increase to a vast display space
all around the tablet to our right to
our left
and in front of us so how can we use
that and
there's different uh designs that we can
go i'm just suggesting one design here
that we were
looking at in which you have the
tablet and we could use the space above
the tablet for
different semantics layers versions
remarks
a inner working of the application
we can use a larger space for our
interaction a bit where we actually move
uh the in the physical screen
mapping to that bigger screen virtual
screen so that we can use the
um a bigger input space
and we could use the display space
around us to show different views of the
data
um different tabs different uh
spreadsheets uh that we can uh
reach out and use as well as
um overviews uh
in front of us that enable us fast
access and
detection of changes
so let's take an example of a
spreadsheet
such as excel right now we are
working on the tablet and
when we use our depth information we can
see things which are behind
uh the tablet the tablet display is very
simple
it's a regular grid of data which is
part of its attractivity
and simplicity and easy to learn but
it's
harder to see how a function
is built up or how the data flows in
debugging or even if you have
figures and you want to change the
sources for it
by enabling additional uh
semantic layers and having nodes in
those
we can easily make manipulations
and modifications or debugging
also it enables us to get help
where we need it for example if we need
a menu here
we don't need to go to the edge of the
view we can tilt the
stylus up and reach that menu at
different levels
we can generate nodes that uh
summarize ranges in the data
in the spreadsheet and have those
clustered display
easy to copy and use for different
applications
and no
and finally we are tracking
our hands both the dominant hand with
the stylus a non-dominant hand might
touch the screen just as well
we have our head moving uh wearing a
head mounted display we can even have uh
eye gaze and by doing that we can
quickly
jump around and map our limited
input space to different parts of the
data
so that we could have very uh
fast and efficient way to work
up till now i was uh describing the work
as a stand-alone i go to some space and
i unpack
a virtual office around me however
different spaces look different they
might have
obstacles bigger smaller they might have
other people and the application should
be aware of that because it could affect
the way we work
so if i want to go on an airplane
and just unpack my
multi-screen environment and be able to
uh
work it i might ignore the fact that
i me maybe in an environment that the
co-worker might come and
talk to me the stewardess in the
airplane might come and
ask me questions and i also want to use
affordances in the environment for
example i want if i draw
that it will be on some supporting
surface
and not arbitrarily in space so we need
the applications to be
a word even more than that what we
want is a magical application that we
write once but then it can run
differently
in different spaces according to
the their affordances so we develop a
system called
flair fast layout for augmented reality
experiences
that is using learned rules or
predetermined rules
to lay out the
workspace or game for that matter
in the environment regardless of
whatever the environment shape
is and balance between the limitation of
the environment
and the need of the user or the game
um so i could for example go to my
office or my
preferred environment and and just plan
how things gonna be my contacts gonna be
on my
right and updates gonna be on the left
and the main document in the center and
so on
and then pack virtually everything and
whenever i go
to uh some place it will unpack in a way
that will be both
familiar to me i expect the contact to
be on my right
but also uh fit the environment
so we to do that we look at the
environment whether it is using
color cameras such as on the head
mounted display
or depth cameras as hololens have
them or maybe using uh
the motion of the color cameras to
generate
reconstruction of the environment on the
fly
and then by analyzing it find out
for semantics affordances in the scene
walls or places that will be great to
put displays on
tables and places that could be work
surfaces
areas where people are walking around
maybe you want to avoid that
and so on and
for augmented reality application where
we do see the real world we also
look at um the silency which is a
measure of
busyness of the world around you maybe
we don't want to
um put a virtual monitor where there is
already a monitor that we need to see or
signs
and uh giving that as an input to the
system
as well as our preference for uh
the work or the needs of the game we can
adapt for each environment so for
each room for example the game on the
left looks different but
it's playable and uh
it's it still obeys all the rules
of uh the game now
not just monitors and input spaces also
collaborators uh may be represented in
our space around us
and this representation should be
updated as
the environment changes for example
someone gets into the scene
in this uh system which is a projection
based system
uh you can see that the collaborator
is mapped to a chair
but when that chair is taking we map it
to a different chair
it could be that these had to be
[Music]
done in parallel for multiple
users and their displays
um another issue that we're dealing with
is privacy and in this time not privacy
from prying eyes
around the user but the actual
developers
of the applications the more
applications know and been mapped to the
environment
they potentially knows about the user
and we don't want that
we would like to generate a sandbox
by the local operating system so that an
application might come
in and described its need
these and these uh displays they need to
be
that uh accessible for the user
these and these surfaces for input and
as the uh operating system accumulate
demand from multiple
applications it could assign them
accordingly
without having any information leaks
back to
the application
and very super important
subject for us is enabling
accessibility to people
who might have difficulties to use them
at at this point in
virtual reality and augmented reality
use it's mostly
looking at creating getting the market
big and
uh and less fitted for uh
special needs and which
we try to look at at it for example
here you see a a video of simulating how
a person with
a low vision will see
a virtual reality application now
according to the world health of
uh organization in 2018 there were more
than
uh 217 million people
worldwide with low vision and by low
vision i mean
that glasses or lenses uh
cannot correct the limitation it could
be a variety
of uh effects such as blurriness
uh limited field of view tunnel vision
spots in the field of view that you
don't see sensitivity to light
lack of sensing depth
or assessing distances and so on
so to enable both users to use
applications that exist as well as
developer
to uh easily apply
[Music]
solutions for the user
we developed a toolkit called seeing vr
which stretches from simple tools such
as an automatic zooming when you look
at an object to segmentation of
objects and show better way to separate
between there where one starts on the
other end
to enhancement of text to readout of
text and
and all that is uh being
shipped out as an open source
uh toolkit which you can find in
this address as well as
in
[Music]
other publications and project pages
that we'll share
at the end of the webinar
so i just want to thank of course
such work was not done by a single
person done by a lot
of people where researchers from
microsoft
research uh currently and in the past
um professors from other universities
that collaborated with us
students and uh research interns
which all worked hard on those
projects so where can we
take the technology uh further i mean
this is a really short webinar and
cannot cover
all the work that we did or work that
can be done in
this area
we are very excited about the fact that
uh
this combination of uh smart systems
that
are aware of the user needs as well as
the changing environments around the
user
and could change the work environment
accordingly
can give us we also
think that this virtual space can enable
people to do things that they couldn't
do
in the real world or a level the playing
field for people with physical
limitations
for example the images that you see on
the right or from a work where
a person is walking in the microsoft
campus
and the system show him as if he's in a
remote site in this case in
lower manhattan but it could be in
a different lab in europe and
while the system is aware of
obstacles and people around it and make
sure that he walks safely
it's also should be a a
bridge between his
physical environment and the environment
of the remote site that he visited
and technologies like i showed and this
we hope that will open up uh jobs for
people that
leave remotely from uh uh
the offices that has a problem to access
the the offices maybe
lower needs for transportation
uh can reduce the
get the the jump or the ramp up that
we need to go when we go from one task
to another
uh control external disturbances and
more
so to summarize uh we
hope that the freedom of the mixed
reality
along with better sensing
will be a fertile ground for further
research that will change the way that
we work in the future and we sure hope
that
when we maybe talk about that in a few
years to the future we'll be surprised
of what we actually saw
and by this i will go
end up this webinar and open
for questions thank you all and i will
uh refer you to our
link page for uh additional content
thanks
hi everyone thanks for attending the uh
enhancing mobile work and productivity
with virtual reality webinar
and now we're in the live q a
session i'm mia lopic and
over the next 15 minutes give a take
we're going to be answering top
questions submitted by the audience so
let's get started let me look at the
questions
uh okay
so uh the first question that i get
okay is how much of my work do i do
in vr and mr and
uh that's a good question because we are
still in a process of uh getting the
hmbs to be
good enough for work there are several
issues that need to be dealt in order to
really be able to uh
work for a long hours in hmds
one is the quality of the lenses which
right now
are quite low because it's aimed at
um entertainment mostly but
uh if you buying it for work and you
think of it as a
large 4k display
then you might be able to invest more
in the hmds than and you can see
in hmds such as above 1000
hundred dollars there you start to to
get really good lenses
um second is you need a resolution for
the text
which we are getting there if we're
looking at the hmds commercial engineers
like
the hp uh ones um
and obviously we want it to be light now
given that i do quite a lot
in vr because that's my work
and if i go uh in a situation such as
travel then i i think it's uh
it's a no-brainer it gives me a
a very uh private and expensive
display that i could use when working
how would vr help someone with glaucoma
um in general uh you can think of
uh an hmd as a private display that
is um close to the eye
and mostly uh although the the eyeball
is rotating it's closer to uh
the eye coordinate system than say an
external
uh display and that could give us
different uh uh things that can help
people with vision problems such as
limiting the display into a small part
of the field of view which is better for
people
and it could sharpen
information uh it could add additional
uh cues to highlight things that you
might look at and
the hmd gives us a rough
uh view direction that people look at so
uh if you will see look at the work of
the same vr you'll see
a different slew of uh
techniques that can help people i don't
know if that's specific to glaucoma but
it does range a
different kind of artifact
um
what would be the perceptual implication
of
phobia to display uh
perceptual um
i'm not sure can you send a bit more uh
detail in your question um
and uh there was
let's see more questions coming in
um
okay so um again you have to uh
there's an ask uh questions about how to
use
uh handle damage by hand mounted
glasses which i think i said something
and also neck injury
uh we did the specific work on that um
where you think of an hmd or vr as a
mean to uh mediate the visual input for
the user so
uh we could do things such as limited
head rotation
maybe uh if we know that a certain
direction is problematic we can try to
arrange information in a way that will
limit that rotation
regarding the the question is that it's
great to
see that you're looking at into
accessibility in xr early on is there a
goal
from msr to enable xr as an
accessibility early on
or is it more an opportunistic basis no
it's actually we do try to incorporate
accessibility into
many things we do starting on
and there is we work in coordination
with their specific accessibility teams
both for windows
and office and
a mark tries to uh
work on that uh
is it possible to skip the traditional
input devices for computing
uh for vr like recreating keyboards and
just
jump into speech speech or brain
interface control
um potentially but you could say
this is not necessarily a vr question
is there a potential to go beyond the
mouse and keyboard
in general for typing and up till now it
was really hard
to do speech has a
problem of privacy as well as
annoying people around you while um
brain interface might be a good uh thing
i don't think it's right now
as accurate as you would like it to be
for uh
um sort of brain typing
and let's see um
it seems though as hololens would
support more enhanced virtual productive
environments based on being able to
maintain awareness of the natural
environment
is ms working on more productivity
applications
for homeland too yes for sure ms is
working on
a more productivity application for that
regarding the uh um
environment awareness this is uh quite a
high
level awareness which you could script
out
different behaviors that you could
see between the either the ar
display or even vr and what's happening
in your
environment this currently is not
in the main direction of holland's which
looking at the
[Music]
field workers uh and specific tasks but
it might be um
can vr project be afforded by uh people
financially challenged
our vr project costly um
right now it's the emerging technology
it might be
costlier than it should be but i clearly
see how
hmds are becoming uh a commodity you can
already
buy a quite good one such as the uh
oculus quest 2 for uh 300
or maybe even less and i can clearly see
how it will go
[Music]
lower than that and if you are trying to
compare them to
uh equivalent displays that you need to
buy to
get you a large working environment i
think they're already getting there
to be competitive in price
how developers can use vr for example
id like visual studio um
right now there are several standards of
vr that coming out like
open vr open xr microsoft has
a standard for mr
uh which tries as much as possible to
remove the load from
developers and enables you to do uh
easy development there and yes within
visual studio too
um
[Music]
prolonged um psychological impact on
human mind
[Music]
to incident of a non-physical world
um we haven't
done really long i mean we
mostly looking at the contents of
a work day
and i must say that
there's a obviously
effect such as people looking at screens
uh all day long uh it's a bit
better by the way from uh from screen
because it does react to what you do and
uh
and movement and they try as much as
possible to make the
uh head-up display as close to uh your
uh natural display in particular for ar
i don't think there are
any uh significant uh
effects there uh let me
look at questions that already has
has the coffee pandemic impacted the xr
industry in your opinion
um well it affected every industry i
would say
um for uh xr industry it's plus and
minus
uh obviously a development
is harder in at that time
and especially when you want to do user
studies and you
cannot meet your participants you have
to send them
hardware it's harder but on the other
hand
it gives more focus on the need for
better communication and better getting
out
of your current environment which
is a boost for uh this area
okay um let's see um
with a question about
meeting rooms in a vr
sense and that will be interesting
because
uh a i believe there will be more
people calling from afar as well as
there's a mix between
people in the same room as well as
people outside
and what we do think and try to do is to
make
uh people that call from outside which
right now
do suffer from the fact that a they
don't have a physical
uh um
instance in the meeting room they're
just voice
from afar that hard to get in they don't
hear well
for uh the um the other
participants they don't have what we
call a reference space
which is between the body of the
participants
and say a task or a document they cannot
point or
give other movement gestures and
we hope that vr ar can help us
on this sense um
can we our project be integrated with
robotics or
hci of course they can and
and people actually do that
whether it is that you put yourself
as guiding off a robot or
that you represent your
physical being in the remote space by a
robot
this is something that we
did work on
okay
what is your view on the key driver to
make
work in vr ubiquitous do you think call
openation could
play a big role or even be a key driver
especially now that people have a hard
time to meet physically
um yes
i mean i i thought before but
um in in general when we look at the
vr ar it's a way to mediate our
sensing we right now mostly mediate our
visual
and audio we are working hard also on
haptics you can see that
in my web page and
the the target for that is to
modify the environment around the user
to better
fit the task that she needs to do
so if the the task is right now to
uh collaborate with other people
then uh we are looking at
ways that uh this could be
enhanced with vr such as representing uh
people uh gays and
body uh gestures that can
help uh working together
uh there is a funny uh issue of
uh hmds that when people wear them they
actually block their
facial view and expression which is
important
but this is also being worked out in two
different ways one
is making the display small light and
transparent as possible like regular
glasses so you actually see your
[Music]
collaborators on the other hand is
machine learning
based reconstruction of the face from
internal sensors
in terms of those prototypes for typing
the keyboards and
hands precisely i saw it still use the
optical
motion tracking solution uh
are there any prototypes that can
achieve
that higher accuracy using via using
only
cameras on the hmb so
um in the example that you saw in the
video as well as in
uh hololens or uh oculus to use the
cameras only the cameras on the hmd
nothing else
a lot of questions on accessibility
which is great
you know we are projects intend to help
people with disabilities or blind people
yes a we did work several things for
blind people
whether it is uh um generating
and haptic uh a king that people can
walk within a virtual environment and
they
actually hear the audio from tapping the
uh
the chain on object whatever material it
is
or where it is from and we show that
people can actually go through a virtual
environment for example in a game
looking forward treasures much faster
when
they do that
sorry we also looking
at people with disabilities and
how we can use
modification of the emotions to
let them in the virtual world which is
non-physical
behave without any physical limitations
question
[Music]
any movement towards smaller glasses yes
there are
i'm not developing uh hmd hardware but
uh we do see that from almost uh
any major company as well as small ones
uh
while you work in vr how do you get
notification when your office mate wants
to talk to you
so um we are
um and that we we use both cameras that
are
on the hmb as well and here i go beyond
uh what i display here which mostly was
just using the off-the-shelf
hmd as well as the laptop and i could
use both uh the laptop camera
as well as the
other sensors that we can put on the hmd
like deck cameras
and those can give the system
uh full knowledge about what's happening
around where
are people walking is the person uh
coming closer to the user or uh
his face is facing the user and do they
talk and when that happens we
way before they start talking we want to
start to present them
in the vr world so it will not generate
any surprise to uh
be a person that suddenly hears an audio
coming from outside
so the more you are uh
affecting the application based on
what's happening outside uh
the the less need users have to uh
remove their headset and can just
continue working
um we even look at uh
more immersive applications such as
games and how
to uh incorporate uh real world
um interruptions into the game without
with letting the person be safe and
attentive to the world but not a
breaking immersion
um
do you have done vr projects to for
autistic and special children i
myself have not but other people are
working on that uh so i
cannot really tell a lot about that
um
how does 5g introduction change the
current vr interaction in
multi-space location very very good
question
it uh it will have major change in
several issues
one is the ability to transfer
more information from
far away sites into the user and
very important lower latency as you do
that so
you can actually feel as if you are
in a faraway space so we
are running out of time uh
let's see if there's any other
quick question i could answer
uh
the next step beyond office productivity
the future work
towards virtual laboratory productivity
so we didn't look specifically of
laboratory but if the issue is
getting physical objects moving them for
different places do our operations yes
for sure we do
we again there's a very large
research effort you can see on my
webpage
that is related to haptics and how we
could
actually feel that we're manipulating
objects
uh far away and have as much
uh tactile rendering to do so
so i'll refer you to that and
uh with this i will thank you all for uh
attending today uh we appreciate your
participation and interest
and if you're interested to learn more
and we listed some great resources
in the resource list you can find them
right to
your screen the list includes our
published
papers that relate to this you can find
more papers in our
personal webpages links to uh project
pages
and also a link to the same vr toolkit
i hope you all enjoy this webinar and
have a great day
thank you